roman pierce is an essential part of the
fast and furious family and has
undergone perhaps the biggest character
change in the franchise
this is his story from his teen years
growing up alongside brian o'connor to
his role as one of the most integral
members of dominic tyreto's crew
not much is known about roman's youth
but it can be inferred that a life of
crime was pretty much
always in the cards for him born and
raised alongside brian o'connor
in barstow california roman and brian
were predisposed to getting into
trouble in high school their only
wholesome activity seemed to be sports
however it wasn't long before all that
dried up and the duo found their way on
the mean streets by being particularly
good with cars
however somewhere along the line the
dynamic duo separated while brian
decided to pursue a life in law
enforcement
roman took the opposite path and got
involved in a local car stealing
operation
one day police raided his garage to find
he was keeping stolen cars inside he
always wondered if brian ratted him out
and spent years behind bars and then
under house arrest
asking himself that same question over
and over again
in the course of stewing on whether his
childhood friend betrayed him
he lost his trust in other people when
the audience is introduced to roman and
too fast too furious he's a very angry
young man
who has a massive problem with authority
particularly the police
and has no interest in reconnecting with
brian o'connor
after the events of the fast and the
furious brian o'connor ends up on the
run from the law he makes his way to
miami where he gets involved in the
local street racing community but is
eventually picked up by the fbi
fortunately his skills make him more
useful in the field
than behind bars and he is offered the
job of posing undercover as a driver for
notorious drug kingpin
carter varon but he needs a partner it's
unclear if his past with roman weighs on
his conscience
or if he just knows roman is the right
man for the job regardless
brian insists that his old buddy is the
only one who can assist him in his
mission
he travels back to barstow to find his
friend under house arrest
competing in a demolition derby after
three years behind bars
roman now lives in a trailer and
supports himself with his derby winnings
brian offers him a chance to get off
house arrest and have his criminal
record wiped clean by assisting the fbi
roman ignores the deal at first but
becomes enraged when brian has the gall
to call him by his nickname
only my homeboy is calling me wrong the
two fight and brian is able to best his
old friend who reluctantly agrees to
take the deal
it isn't the last fight that roman loses
in the franchise
and it certainly isn't the last thing he
reluctantly agrees to do for brian
although roman is no stranger to the
type of driving that this
undercover mission requires he's
definitely in over his head when it
comes to the police work
in his dealings with varon he's
combative and even demands more money
in a move that could absolutely sour the
deal they've worked so hard to achieve
still he manages to get hired alongside
brian for a job
running cash for the criminal however
they both quickly realize
things aren't what they seem after
discovering fbi trackers in their cars
and learning that
officers are aware that varon plans to
kill his drivers as soon as the job is
done
they realize they have to take matters
into their own hands the two boys from
barstow hatch a plan to get everyone in
the miami racing community
to conduct a big scramble of cars their
intent is to cover their exit once the
police start pursuing them and the money
their plan works but it turns out that
varon gave them a dummy drop
off location roman escapes clean but he
knows that brian is caught in the hands
of a madman with no backup
this is when he makes the decision that
changes his life forever
roman goes back for his friend despite
all the hard feelings he has
about getting arrested all those years
ago
family never leaves a brother behind
roman crashes his car into brian's
saving him from getting executed the two
then pursue verone onto his yacht
by jumping their car directly onto it
causing roman to break his arm
fortunately they're able to take down
verone and make good on their deal with
the fbi
with their criminal records expunged
roman reveals that he hid some of
verone's money on his person
rather than turning it in for evidence
with that the reunited friends ride off
into the sunset while the arc of too
fast too furious may look like a simple
story of two friends reconciling their
relationship
ends up meaning more in the context of
the larger franchise
brian reveals in the film that his
decision to let dom go
rather than arrest him at the end of the
fast and the furious was motivated out
of guilt over what happened to roman
years earlier
therefore one could argue that the
origin of the fast family is rooted in
roman and brian's friendship
rather than brian and dom's if roman and
brian hadn't had such a long history
together
the group may well never have formed
roman doesn't return to the fast
franchise again
until brian and dom are back together as
criminal partners on the wrong side of a
wanted poster in fast five when a
brazilian crime lord pins the murder of
a dea
agent on them they decide to rob him of
a hundred million dollars
however they need help among the crack
team members they bring in for the job
is roman pearce
the resident talker but roman brings a
lot more to the table than just his gift
of gap he's proven he can fight
drive and is up for the crazy stunts the
group decides to pull off
even if he is often the most reluctant
to do so this just went from mission
impossible
to mission and freaking sanity that
reluctance actually serves as an
asset to the group when roman questions
the real reason for the score
roman is unafraid to stand up to dom and
suggest that while the money is
definitely tempting
it feels like dom's motivation is
personal this forces dom to get real
with the people he brought in
and to be completely open and
transparent with them going forward it's
also on this job that roman's friendship
with fellow miami car enthusiast tej
becomes apparent roman has everything he
needs after the team's success in brazil
he's fabulously rich owns a private jet
and even has access to rare and
expensive cars
moreover by this point he's a
full-fledged member of the family so
even though he doesn't know letty when
dom asks for his help he travels to
london to help rescue her
it helps that brian has worked out a
deal for everyone to get full pardons in
exchange for stopping the criminal
enterprise that leddy is working with
for roman this means fighting a tank the
group eventually realizes that the
leader of letty's new gang owen shaw is
trying to attack
a heavily armored convoy roman is out in
front of everyone when a tank is
revealed
although he's typically considered the
reluctant and cowardly one in the group
roman steps up in a major way in fact he
nearly sacrifices his life by getting
out in front of the tank
and drawing its fire he manages to dodge
the blast
although his car is severely damaged he
makes a daring escape by linking the
deadweight car to the tank and knocking
it off a bridge
an almost single-handedly taking out the
tank roman graduates to a whole new
level of criminality in world saving
after narrowly avoiding being sucked
into a jet engine while taking down owen
shaw
roman and the rest of dom's family are
finally allowed to return to los angeles
after helping apprehend the terrorists
life is grand
until owen shaw's brother deckard blows
it up that's when roman and the others
are recruited by mr nobody to help him
find a piece of revolutionary tracking
technology
in exchange for revenge on deckard
always the skeptic
roman says that he's tired of taking
orders and insists on revamping the
government's plan
however the plan gets away from him and
roman chickens out when tasked with
parachuting out of an airplane to attack
an armored convoy but tej takes matters
into his own hands and manually ejects
him
although he drifts off course causing
him to show up a little late
roman arrives just in the nick of time
to help their plan succeed
roman proves invaluable to the crew yet
again in abu dhabi when brian dominic
and letty desperately need a distraction
shine brightly like only roman pierce
can do
with that roman picks up the microphone
and successfully distracts the crowd
with an impromptu speech
before being accosted by security
fortunately by that time
he's caused enough of a distraction for
the rest of the team to pull off their
mission
and he and letty are able to escape in
the ensuing ruckus
afterwards he rejoins the team as they
head back to los angeles there his
knowledge of the streets he grew up on
proves useful in outfoxing the
terrorists using the tracking system
at this point roman and the rest of the
gang are a well-oiled world-saving crime
machine
that's why he doesn't think twice about
accepting a call from dominic
to get the band back together to steal
an emp in berlin in fate of the furious
however he is blindsided by dominic
betraying them and running off to
deliver the emp
to a new enemy named cipher like the
rest of the crew
roman is completely shocked by dom's
seemingly shifting allegiances
on top of that he feels insulted when he
learns he just missed the top 10 of
interpol's most wanted list
top ten that's all right
well not you roman what do you mean you
just missed the cut you're number 11.
still despite roman's personal feelings
of disrespect
he's all in for the mission he suggests
bringing in brian but he's reminded that
the group agreed at the end of furious 7
to leave him out of their dangerous
lifestyle from then on roman reluctantly
agrees to let mr nobody and letty call
the shots
as they chase dominic to new york city
only for his vehicle to be
incapacitated by dom even on the heels
of yet another betrayal
roman refuses to give up on family he
accompanies the rest of the team to
russia to rescue dominic from cipher
admittedly the deal has been sweetened a
bit by the sleek lamborghini that he's
given to drive
in what are by far the most daring
conditions roman has handled a vehicle
and yet
he takes the bright orange sports car
out onto the ice as he attempts to
outrun a moving submarine
unfortunately it doesn't work out and he
loses yet another car
but he is able to take down a decent
number of enemies because he's rescued
by tesh
and they're able to successfully save
dom and the rest of the world once again
just when it seems like there's nowhere
else for roman to go
an old enemy from dominic's past returns
and forces the gang to new heights
literally in the trailers for 2021's f9
we see roman and tej get even more
experimental than they already have
by taking a car that has been attached
to a rocket engine up into the
atmosphere
please tell me that's not a pontiac
fiero strapped to a rocket engine
i don't wanna die one wonders as the
movies continue
how much further roman's story might go
as the sky is clearly not the limit
could the troubled young kid who was
once busted for stealing cars be headed
on a world-saving mission to outer space
only time will tell but if the past
proves anything it's that we should
never underestimate
roman pairs check out one of our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
fast and the furious are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one